it was an eventful start to my journey
to the deep ropes snagged in the
propeller of our sub and just me to free
them while bobbing on the surface of the
Indian Ocean back onboard an explosion
of expelled air and we left our
mothership and the surface behind me in
my yellow submarine descending with
another net and sub the light fading
fast sixty meters down we paused to take
a sample from a sea fan a kind of coral
for further analysis my pilot Robert
just as odd as I was
just undiscovered it's I grew up in the
mountains of North Carolina and I was
flying
then it was my turn to do some science
[Applause]
measuring out the distance we were
drifting so researchers monitoring video
could assess the amount and variety of
life and there was plenty of it a
hammerhead shark an eagle ray and
schools of fish we sank down the steep
mountainside 200 metres well into the
ocean twilight zone the light almost
gone we could be spaceships exploring
another planet coming up then it was
time to rise once again a battery's low
and the strong currents a challenge for
the sub pilots in this Indian Ocean it's
just uncharted no one's been down here
so we had no real previous indication of
what we might expect so it's been a
really interesting journey my journey
had been extraordinary the seer in just
a few days will dive again to broadcast
the first ever live programs from
underwater bringing home the wonder of
the deep Thomas More Sky News in the
Seychelles